welcome to this video as young Asia is I
probably so I'm not able and not allowed
to play 185 so I'm playing the Sicilian
someone requests the dragons but I
really don't feel comfortable with that
maybe some other Sicilian that is sharp
okay is going for this in the first
place okay maybe 96 that's one of the
sharper moves okay going to break the
pin maybe I can get the no I don't get I
don't get them Bishop am ok let's go be
five yeah I know it looks looks a lot
like a real pest but yeah it's probably
it's probably natural tendency but
that's right you know I tried um so we
should be 74 Quincy 7 hmm probably
pretty decent position for whitey
no tea for a default looks fine now he
may can delay that like d3 but rock t
one looks like he wants to go before can
I go with this my my funky regrouping
quick could be okay even why not well it
shows that knowledge of a particular
opening line or setup can be useful in
entirely different scenarios so out of
the sicilian i created a group of vets
after what okay so i would like to play
night we ate but she has prevented that
mmhmm yeah and night does not want to go
to be seven but maybe it's okay here
because i get to the a file so quickly
we can get rooks traded yeah so he wants
to go night at five which is not really
a problem mm-hmm so maybe you're up here
trying to trade our looks
my somewhat yeah somewhat rather huge
experience by now with this kind of
position I really has taught me that
trading rooks is quite helpful black his
leg is suffering a little bit from lack
of space and if i can trade rooks and if
i can trade the dark squared bishop
those two are key i'm normally quite ok
so let's see what is doing ok it's
putting this into f5 an interesting
decision I cannot keep this piece there
so I have to take it so mm-hmm c4 may be
empty for b5 was hanging and this way
I'm also isolating the d5 pawn from his
the rest of his camp I might probably
not yet able damn I'm threatening maybe
rook a 1 ok ok 1 mu k 1 95 but it looks
a bit if he on the long diagonal so
going to control he's totally ignoring
that yeah but now I can take it I really
can I don't see any problem with that
one day she said Bishop e7 Queenie sound
i also have f4 as a really great square
for my night you probably will play
Bishop t2 just retreat the night trading
looks like yeah or they I am that's the
second the second series option we are
getting the night somewhere close to his
King would be great like 9i tear for
would be excellent but I don't don't see
how to get this in
may be here for Luke a 8 and having a
look at that this knight on f3 that
might be a vulnerable piece
and okay I prepare ok this is also quite
important 925 interesting see
threatening f6 no he isn't I can take
with the night ok I'm trading ideas
after the trade I'm directly threatening
Queen a one if he goes f6 I can teach
other night and I'm covering h7 yeah but
isn't a queen a 1 a good move Queen a
one checking that with check queen dcs
quindi one after that nighty for Bishop
if form and then then actually night f4
is good ok so I'm going for that Queen a
one using this pin see what is hanging
with check ok um yeah so if i take here
only for I mean and then retreat the
night the question is where to be 64
possible g5 mean it's a bit tight down
there now on I'd to f4 I also would be
great yeah let's do that let's try to
shoot for a form ok
one problem is that my porn see mb5
especially can become vulnerable to a
bishop c6 move okay he's directly doing
this I can trade and go night a form one
gt5 my half knots not working ok I have
to attach saturator anyway night a form
mmm that's not so easy actually 94
Bishop see one spirit coming to c 6 i'm
morning itself is a problem really is
hmm see a good way to continue here to
play for an advantage I mean I can do
something like that which is ok but I
don't see how I'm playing for win now
hmm ok weird if he goes back then 984 it
stalls the whole thing a little bit
Jim I suspect this is quite quite Jewish
beef before here yes good actually and
then before
h6 Bishop g5 would be very neat to get
in it sources too ambitious I think I
can try for that it is a bit ambitious
okay I know if I'm going back it's not
good I can sell maybe I have to do that
sure brah home drown nate is a draw i
mean i can theoretically speaking shoot
for a time when mud it's a draw my
points on dark squares this looks bad I
know but I can go king of seven and just
stay there is no way for him to come
through him yeah I wonder is there
something something here to preserve an
advantage I suspect there should be
something what did I miss 97 is much
better now here I actually get in d5
yeah that's true if he does that now I
can take him it's not attacking the
night that's a huge difference okay okay
okay this was the key moment where I
spoiled it I really think I should win
now here I won the big sent to pawn and
check got good control we never yeah
computer is agreeing with all my mousse
and now I just have to go 97 but after
that he had some it's probably a draw I
don't really I don't really see what to
do this this now here it seems to be a
draw okay I think he has to take channel
oops I'm sorry that was totally wrong
button he has to take their I take here
and now 93 and before is the draw try to
try it for more but here I have to I
have to enter the whole thing here yeah
getting rid of the pawns
um if I'm going so let's say yeah I'm
risking things probably I its literal
can do this for this end this which is
to completely drawn yeah check but what
can you do it is a draw at the end but
it was a fairly interesting game so
thanks for watching